you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts multi-parameter cell
cycle analysis presented by dr. james
jacob berger professor emeritus and
director of cytometry a microscopy core
Case Western Reserve University
I am Alexis Krause of laborat and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's webinar is part of the protein
and cell analysis education series
brought to you by leopards and sponsored
by thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information on our sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher comm
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want
during the presentation to do schoo
simply type them into that ask a
question box and click on the send
button well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits so
without further ado dr. Jacob Berger you
may now begin your presentation
Thank You Alexis hello everyone
the term cell cycle analysis has come to
define psychometric gassings to count
cells in cell cycle phases compartments
or state I'll use these words throughout
the talk interchangeably this slide
shows a single parameter histogram in
the upper left for cells stained for DNA
content which gives us three phases g1 s
and g2 plus ma2 parameter plot in the
lower left shows cells staying for DNA
content plus a mitotic marker which then
gives us four phases g1 s g2 and M M is
synonymous with the mitotic phase stages
of the cell cycle g1 ourselves with one
genome SS cells that are synthesizing
the second genome and g2 and M ourselves
with two genomes on the right the three
parameter plot shows cells stained for
DNA content a mitotic marker and two
cyclin proteins these are proteins that
oscillate periodically and regulate the
cell cycle these data create a multi
compartment model of contiguous obligate
states that cells pass through during
the cell cycle and that is multi
parametric cell cycle analysis in
general DNA is the primary base marker
it provides a three compartment
subdivision ordered in time g1 then s
then g2 plus M periodically expressed
genes or activities subdivide these
phases further with a goal to create a
model with objectively defined
compartments that are unambiguous that
is the cell's pass through each
compartment unidirectionally want this
slide shows two parameter histograms of
data synthesized from expression
profiles of such periodic expression the
upper row contains expression that write
that rises and plateaus within a single
phase the middle row show
expressions that rise across phases in
both Rose cells divided at the plateau
level creating daughter cells that have
half that level in the third and fourth
rows expression rises and declines
within a single phase for example the
first second and fourth columns or cross
phase boundaries in a third column the
inter synthesized patterns based on
ideas but we and others have observed
most of these patterns when looking at
specific marker in many cases the
compartments derived from these patterns
are not unambiguous for example mitotic
markers show elevated expression and
mark mitotic cells but the pattern
contains cells that are entering and
exiting mitosis within the same data
space ie the compartment is ambiguous to
render these ambiguous compartments
unambiguous we need additional markers I
now introduce a fixation and staining
protocol that is extensively published
so the specifics are unimportant other
than the lengthy time it takes to
prepare cells
prior to cytometry key elements are
formaldehyde to fix the cells and
prevent further enzymatic activity
followed by alcoholic denaturation and
permeabilization or detergent
permeabilization without denaturation
different markers are optimized by
variations in this basic protocol since
markers are intracellular optimized
staining requires time which is 30 to 90
minutes depending on the desired data
quality with 90 minutes providing the
highest signal-to-noise ratio further
after antibody incubation 3 washes at 15
minutes each for centrifuge time crop in
the next few slides I'll present data
for k562 cells a human erythroid
leukemia cell line stain for DNA content
fossil s 10 histone h3 which is a
mitotic marker and 2 mitotic cyclins a2
and b1 we'll walk through the result
and data analysis step by step to create
a multi compartment cell cycle analysis
the slide illustrates the first analysis
steps which clean up the data
these include doublet discrimination
exclusion of any anomalies from
perturbed flow and a correction for
signal drift a region is said that
includes singlet cells based on the
shape of the primary DNA signal poles
the first plot shows the signal peak on
the y-axis and the signal area on the X
double its triplets and so on have peak
Heights equal to single cells but area
is equal to multiples of single cells
the middle row shows plots of DNA
content versus time for this run there
are no areas of perturbed flow but if
there were regions would be set used to
exclude incorrectly measured data
however although here the effect is
small there is a continuous decrease in
the signal over time that can be
corrected in the same way as
compensation is applied the quality that
is the CV of the data does not change
over time so the correction improves the
CV of the corrected data compared to
uncorrect data we examine all parameters
for this effect and corrected the
overall effect is severe enough this
doesn't always happen and the causes
behind it or complex is still under
study
since we are going to move continuously
through multi-parameter data space
through bivariate windows i've included
this slide to illustrate the overall
process what is plotted isn't important
because in the following slides we will
go through the process step by step what
is important is the idea that we have
moved through in this case five
parameter data space following the
arrows in a manner that does not exclude
any combination that would equal a cell
cycle state or at least that is the idea
in this example we start at the box
labeled begin and end with the box
labeled end which is the beginning and
end of the cell cycle
the next step is to separate interface
from mitosis that is shown in the panel
on the left
proximal histone h3 and many other
heavily phosphorylated epitopes
increased dramatically when cells enter
mitosis for this epitope and others d
phosphorylation occurs in late mitosis
and continues through immediate early
gene one that's we can segment all M by
gating all 4c cells with elevated
phospho histone h3 in these same plots
of phosphorus grenades 3 vs DNA we can
capture the early g1 cells shown with
the by the arrow and the word newborn in
these same plots of class for histone h3
vs DNA we can capture the early g1 cells
we can check that measurement by
examining cyclin b1 versus histone h3
because of the decreased background of
the small early g1 cells we can separate
early g1 from the rare late M cells that
have partially d phosphorylated histone
h3 and that's shown in the right panel
you
the next steps are to isolate g1 proper
that is - early g1 public g1 and g2 can
be segmented using cyclin a 2 versus DNA
plots with M cells removed by pooling
and logic the remaining cells are in s
the critical g1 F and s g2 boundaries
can be checked by comparing the g1 s and
g2 phase fractions of the DNA
distribution determined by Gaussian
modeling of DNA content but programs
such as mod fit to the frequencies of
cells determined by color coding logic
because there is shape to the cyclin d2
versus DNA S phase component it can be
broken into early s s1 and the remainder
of s s to the plot on the far right
shows the DNA distribution color coded
for g1 s 1 s 2 and G to the next we
segment g1 into two states g1 a and g1
be the importance of segmenting g1 into
two states and uncommitted g1 a and
committed g1 B separates what used to be
called the restriction point which is a
commitment checkpoint the mitotic
cyclins are repressed in the uncommitted
state by activity of the anaphase
promoting complex / cyclist ohm or the
APC / C and as it is inactivated cyclin
b1 expression increases the level is
still low and expression is continuous
therefore it is not a great marker but
at present some information can be
obtained without adding another marker
the left figure shows how we can use the
g1 s boundary f1 is color coded maroon
defined previously and the early g1
cells here are colored black to
determine approximately where to place
the region boundaries the panel on the
right shows the progression of the
states g1 ag1 be s 1 s 2 and G 2 in
terms of cyclin b1 levels
you
we let's turn to em phase we define the
earliest M state p1 as for C cells with
maximum levels of cyclones and rising
levels of costal histone h3 that is
shown in the upper left on the plot of
pH h 3 vs. cyclin a - the previously
defined g2 cells in green define the
critical boundary and the upper boundary
is placed at the cluster edge after
gating only on emselves we plot cyclin
b1 versus cyclin d2 and the pattern
shown in the upper right is segmented at
cluster boundaries in this plot p1 and
p2 are coincident and p2 is defined by
boolean logic that gates that excludes
p1 when the APC C begins to activate
cyclin a2 is degraded and this is
captured spm because cells in this state
correlate with prometaphase when cells
have reached undetectable levels of
cyclin d2 the mitotic checkpoint is
entered with stable high levels of
cyclin b1 and depleted cyclin a - this
state is labeled M because it normally
correlates with metaphase
the cells are treated with the mitotic
spindle inhibitor for example Nakata's
all they arrest here and this state will
become highly populated next cyclin b1
is degraded and this correlates with the
onset of anaphase but the rate of decay
does not correlate well with the
sequence anaphase 1 anaphase 2 and Q
later phase since these states do not
correlate well with morphologically
defined stages we label them l m4 late
mitosis LM 1 is defined by cells with
less than maximum but more than minimum
cyclin b1 that is cells that are
degrading cyclin b1 LM 2 is defined by
cells when cyclin b1 has been degraded
to a minimum within this state there are
additional states that can be defined by
morphology
on a plot of DNA pulse peak versus the
DNA integrated signal for fossil histone
h3 positive cells we observed two
clusters in a transition the reason for
this is that if the psycho meter is well
tuned the late anaphase and telophase
cells look like doublet this is shown in
the lower right panel the cells were the
lowest peak signal that is those
enriched in telophase can be further
subdivided into a group with maximum
fossil histone h3 that is LM 2 C and
those with lower levels LM 2 D the
figure on the lower left shows that
cells divide from L M to C and LM 2 D or
at least that is the working hypothesis
plus in a 3d plot we can visualize most
of the 15 unambiguous states working of
which are sequentially traversed by
unperturbed proliferating cells
an average cell of this population under
the proliferative conditions defined by
the environment at the time of fixation
moves sequentially from G 1 and B 2 LM
to C then optionally move to G 1 and B
or LM to D then to G 1 and B this
provides a continuous backbone onto
which other markers can be mapped now
I'd like to introduce the idea of adding
information obtained from a different
platform
the data are from a laser scanning site
ometer in this case these are a
different attached cell line but in
principle the same samples of fixed and
stained cells that were analyzed by the
flow cytometry previously could be
analyzed in this manner the plot at the
upper left ourselves need for phospho
histone h3 and DNA and I have set a gate
for mitotic cells the plot on the lower
left shows nuclear size on the y-axis
and on the x-axis the density or cyclin
b1 in each cell region are 10 equals the
largest nucleus with the minimum cyclin
b1 density region are 15 equals the
smallest 4c nucleus with maximum cyclin
b1 density if we look at the arctan
images we observed that cyclin b1 is
cytoplasmic and on centrosomes but not
in the nucleus
many of the centrosomes are well
separated at the beginning of mitosis
cyclin b1 first accumulates on the
centrosome which then begins to separate
and each will end up a opposite each
other and create the poles of the
mitotic spindle if we look at the images
in our 13 to the right of our 10 we can
see that cyclin b1 has entered the
nucleus for approximately 50% of the
cells and in those things in which
cyclin b1 is still in the cytoplasm
there are two centrosomes and most are
well separated
we go to our 15 the cells are almost all
in metaphase cyclin b1 is now
cytoplasmic again because the nuclear
membrane is broken down
although the cyclin b1 density is still
high because the cells have rounded up
and cyclin b1 decorates the mitotic
spindle
now I'd like to take a step back and go
over the underlying principle behind the
complex bivariate data patterns we've
been analyzing this slide shows
expression of two parameters over time
the top row is parameter one in the
middle row is parameter to the data our
event self that vary on the y axis that
is for every point in time there are
multiple cells that represent the
expression level if all of the cells in
the population were synchronous the two
parameters are correlated in time when a
proliferating population of cells has
sampled because they are asynchronous
all points along the time line of
expression are represented thus if we
plot parameter 1 versus parameter 2 we
get two parameter histograms as shown in
the bottom row that look like typical
flow cytometry data I've color-coded the
clusters and transitions bottom row and
their corresponding segments in the two
top rows for example the two stable
minima at the beginning and the ends of
the time sequence are ochre and brown
they are represented in the bottom
bivariate plots in the first cluster in
the lower left the sharply rising
expression of parameter one cyan is
correlated with expression of parameter
two at a stable minimum also cyan
therefore the transitional cyan cells
move in quotes to the right in the
parameter one direction and remain fixed
in the parameter two direction in the
bottom of the histogram if the
expression of one parameter is shifted
in time relative to the other parameter
the number of cells populating clusters
and transitions is affected middle and
right columns
now going back to our data from the
laser scanning site ometer if we
calculate the median fluorescence and
plotted on the y axis and plot relative
cell cycle time calculated from the
compartment frequencies on the x axis we
can see the profiles underlying the
parameters here phospho histone h3
expression and cyclin b1 density or any
other marker that we've included and if
we have imaging data then we can do the
same thing for other information by
showing that time related cumulative
change in frequencies for example this
plot shows the parameter expression
profiles and reveals the variation in
entry or passage through the mitotic
stages it can be seen that accumulation
of two centrosomes parallels prophase
and both correlate with the rise in
possible histone h3 equally cyclin b1
enters the nucleus rapidly in all of our
cells over a very short period and this
is followed immediately by entry to
prometaphase the expression of cyclin b1
through this period is maximal and
stable but the density sharply Rises at
the end of prophase metaphase is more
variable but by the time most of the
cells have entered cyclin b1 density
remains high
by the time anaphase begins cyclin b1
density is fallen thus we can
quantitatively correlate expression
movement of molecules and morphological
changes
this is about where we and others have
taken multi parametric cell cycle
analysis so I'd like to make a few
comments and then I'll present some of
our recent work since I can imagine
critics saying that this is all nice but
what real value is this complicated
analysis I'll start on the right side of
this slide first the first practical
application is in pharmacodynamic cell
cycle regulators and other targets that
affect the cell cycle are still rational
approaches in cancer chemotherapy this
type of an assay might provide improved
information and pharmacodynamic studies
and subsequently as a possible
therapeutic guide we have built an
analysis of dnmt1 a target of a deciding
or decided being therapies using a
reduced version of this approach second
for any blood or bone marrow analysis
some subset of this approach could
reduce the complexity of data by
normalizing expression of other
molecules across the cell cycle possibly
reducing the width of data by a factor
of two inquisitively providing high
quality doublet discrimination finally
my good friend David Headley believes
that it is time to use this information
to study the effects of drugs in
therapeutic studies using xena graphs I
believe is Right to the left side these
are the things that I would do going
forward g1 can be compartmentalized just
as we have done for mitosis they're made
there are many candidate markers but
data will be a little more messy because
g1 is more highly variable but I expect
it to break apart in a similar fashion
g2 has a major DNA damage checkpoint
operating this has been extensively
studied and the probes are available to
see if g2 could be as interesting I
would like to do studies that
incorporate data from multiple platforms
interesting
correlated data set using the principles
I've outlined imaging is my favorite but
foot scan is under explored and the work
of George pertain and Sergei Guralnik
demonstrate that differential
permeabilization may be a fruitful way
to get at molecular sequestration I
think the day has come for a new
generation of probes and Camel
antibodies are my favorite in that
regard Multi parametric data should be
analyzed by probability state modeling
see Bruce Bagwell's work on this this
would eliminate or reduce significantly
the number of decisions about where to
set regions finally I think improved
hardware is not out of the question
speaking of improved hardware I'd like
to present some results that I'm very
pleased with here's a reference to a
paper by Goddard at all on acoustic
focusing cytometry this is a technology
where acoustic energy is directed into
the flow cell in such a way that the
center of the stream is a volume where
the waves cancel and there is an energy
absence
thus the cells moved to the center and
once in the center they stayed there
this is illustrated in the next few
images by an illustration on the left
and a photograph on the right
you
thermal Fisher has commercialized this
technology in the attune next-closest a
commoner what this meant to us is that
we could try to develop a semi watchlist
protocol and reduce the time that we
used stain cells
the idea is to wash away the fixative
normally and then incubate in antibodies
in a small volume then add one mark
solution the attune instrument can run a
large volume through rapidly up to one
mil
the instrument can do this because the
cell will all moved to the center and
remain in focus
thus the unwashed large volume sample
might be able to go directly onions from
and after an incubation period and a
dilution
you
here's the protocol without going
through the entire thing it is just like
our standard protocol except we save
time on the washes and acquisition time
with the time savings of two hours five
and a half hours compared to three and a
half hours additionally in these assays
each centrifugation results in the loss
of cells to the extent that starting
with a million cells usually provides
significantly less than a hundred
thousand analyzable events we've not
quantified it but this watchlist assay
does provide a noticeably better cell
recovery will now look at some
comparative data
here are the data comparing the two
asses they are visually equivalent the
top row compares phospho histone h3 vs
cyclin a to the middle row compares
phospho histone h3 vs cyclin b1 and the
bottom row compares cyclin b1 vs cyclin
d2 for mitotic cells
we've quantified five mitotic States as
these are the rarest events the regions
are shown in the bottom row
so
the result there is not a significant
difference between the percentages of
cells within each compartment by the
levels of cyclin D 2 and B 1 in the
cells therefore this is a significant
step forward for this kind of work and
since I've made the comments that I
would ordinarily save for the summary
I'll stop here
one more thing the work shown in this
talk depended on the work of many people
over many years from my own laboratory
and those of many others the reference
is listed on this slide
or reviews with work with extensive
references to our work and that of
others thank you for listening
the people who did the work at Case
Western Reserve University or Tammy
Stefan and Phil of stunning experimental
side bikes from Kowski and Ellison
tippling on the instrument side from
thermo Fisher Susanne Loman ran our
initial experiments and Brian wertham
provided access to the instrument
Jolene Bradford and mike Ward were
critical for moving this project forward
and we continue to work with them on
other projects
thank you dr. jacob berger for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just type
them into the ask a question box and
click on the send button will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the pression presentation
questions we do not have time for today
will be answered by dr. jacob berger via
email following the presentation
our first question is presumably
information increases with the addition
of parameters is the relationship simple
and if so what is the relationship
between information and parameter number
um as I look at this in some detail and
the short answer is that there's no
simple relationship I have the feeling
that we get on hit paydirt early on with
parameters that were a more informative
/ / 10 I expect to get per parameter in
the future but for sure a parameter an
additional parameter should add at least
one piece of information or it's
redundant and it's probably not
unthinkable that two or three pieces of
information might be added per parameter
that's about all I know about
our next question is you have presented
an analytical scheme as a backbone with
the idea that this is definitely
extensible have you tested this idea
the short answer is no I haven't the
there's no reason that I can possibly
think of that would prevent that from
being true the salt theoretically it's
doable but that but a real test of it is
still needs to be done
and it looks like we have time for one
more question can you give some examples
of when a bill wash or minimal wash
protocol will be effective
um yes I think the that well as far as
I'm concerned is it's effective almost
always because it saves time but I think
the perhaps more important case would be
for things like clinical samples that
are very limited in cell numbers so the
idea of then not losing cells through
centrifugation
comes to the forefront and the idea of
incubating with antibodies and then just
diluting up and running and being able
to run almost the entire sample is very
appealing especially for clinical
samples we did a study here recently
that was published recently on
sickle-cell heat sickle cell disease and
treatment of patients with decide to
beat low dose decided being to
reactivate fetal hemoglobin and what we
were looking for was the decrease in
dnmt1 as a function of the decide of
being dough and the all of the samples
had been done prior to us developing the
assay and we didn't have any input into
how the samples were prepared those
samples were I don't remember the exact
cell numbers but it was very few cells
something like a couple of hundred
thousand in a relatively large volume a
fixative so precious samples that where
we really didn't want to lose any we
didn't want to lose any cells and so in
that case the no wash'd approach which
is a almost a lifesaver it's not that it
can't be done you know with washing but
I certainly much happier with the no
wash solution
thank you again dr. Jacob Berger do you
have any final comments for our audience
ah no I hope you enjoyed the seminar the
webinar and my email is I think in the
credits or whatever and I'm happy to
answer any questions if somebody has
them after the fact through email
I would like to once again thank dr.
Jacob Berger for his presentation I
would also like to thank leverage and
thermo Fisher Scientific for making
today's educational webcast possible
questions we did not have time for today
will be answered by dr. jacob berger via
email following this presentation before
we go I'd like to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 30th of
2018 you will receive an email from
labyrinth alerting you when this webcast
is available for replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who rasmus today's live event that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon goodbye